our series changing the game profiles
extraordinary women we're making a
difference now and for future
generations this morning we're
introducing you to a pair of army wives
turned entrepreneurs because the
military relocates families every few
years they've struggled to find jobs
their answer was to create their own
jobs making handbags mark strassman
meant the founders of the business
that's now giving other military spouses
opportunities to work
well it really all started because
cameron and i were military spouses
cameron cruz and lisa bradley you have
the ability to kind of sling it around
your body across your shoulder army
wives saluted for building a made in
america success story their north
carolina handbag company it matches
really well here's why they became
entrepreneurs like many military spouses
they say no one would hire them you're
moving every two to three years on
average and employers see right through
it why hire you when you're gonna leave
right so when i met lisa she was going
through the exact same thing that i was
it was gonna be military spouses that
had to make it for other military
in spouses spirit of rosie the riveter
the world war ii icon in 2011 they
launched our riveter their handbag
business in cameron's attic on a sewing
machine bought with a credit card you
two were the original riveters yep we
were mm-hmm but the goal from the
beginning was to get other military
spouses involved from the they always
wanted to have a national network we
knew that somebody had to stand up and
create the thing that we were we were
searching for
handmade bags made of leather and canvas
durable nothing fussy the military way
they retail on average for a couple
hundred dollars
sowed by military spouses like jennifer
gentry it was the perfect job for me
our riveter tapped into remote work a
decade before most of america
from home gentry sews from a kit of
pre-cut materials a job tailor-made for
nomadic military life nothing changes i
pack up my stuff i pack up my sewing
machine goes and as soon as we get to
the next duty station i unpack it and i
just change my address and keep going
our riveter sales gradually grew a few
hundred bags became a few thousand
then in 2016 an invitation to appear on
shark tank nerve wracking absolutely
terrifying our riveter is about
empowering military spouses mark cuban
invested 100 000
mark you have a deal yes
and the publicity
priceless we sold more handbags in one
night than we did the whole previous 12
months and did it push our riveter to
the next level we have the business
stretch marks to prove it yep we're
jumping in the deep end and we're going
to get after it and see where it takes
us
they tell us sales jumped
percent the next year in 2017
inc magazine named our riveter one of
america's fastest growing companies
could a couple of guys have pulled this
off
i don't think so
but maybe
no comment on that one
[Laughter]
gentry is one of 24 riveters in 15
states individual pieces they sew
this florida factory assembles
annual sales
about 24 000 bags 80 percent of them
online
something special heritage bags a bag
made from a family member's uniform so
this
will become this correct yeah you carry
a piece of family history on your arm
absolutely right and we will make you
your own custom bag out of that material
full of your memories kind of that
history that typically ends up in the
closet in the back of the room
a bag
like this company now serving a larger
purpose
ultimately when you pick up an arbiter
handbag you're picking up an entire
community of men and women sort of
cheering you on while you invest right
back in them
each bag puts that military community on
your shoulders for a change so you can
meet the riveter to see who made your
bag for cbs mornings mark straussman
southern pines north carolina
have she that's awesome
it's a win-win all the way around yeah
and you know what they're proving that
quality control can exist in silos like
that is there so but who knows how to
sew anymore
word is 60 of americans do really yeah i
just got that note is that what the word
is wow i like the word coming through
your ear shout out to them though that
isn't amazing concept yeah and seeing it
realized and i'm glad they're doing well
yeah could um could two men do it no man
she wanted to say men are too dumb
not that